se dan los siguientes números iniciales
y reglas para dos sucesiones vamos a
escribir las dos sucesiones
la asociación x tiene un número inicial
5 y la regla nos indica que cada avance
tendrá una suma de 5 unidades así es que
si tenemos en x como primer número 5
para el segundo sumaremos otros cinco y
cinco más cinco es igual a 10
para el tercero tendremos entonces 10
más 5 es igual a 15 por otra parte la
sucesión que nos dice que el número
inicial será 1 y la regla nos indica que
sumaremos 1 así es que si tenemos 11 el
segundo número será 2 2 más 1 el
siguiente número será 3
para que nosotros logremos hacer esta
gráfica vamos a hacer un poco de espacio
y colocaremos nuestra gráfica así y con
ello tendremos tanto los datos de las
asociaciones como la gráfica
vamos a colocar recuerda que la x la
tenemos en el eje horizontal de las
equis y la aie en el eje vertical de las
10 esto implica que cuando el valor de x
es 5 que nos colocaremos aquí 5 el valor
de eye será 1 tomaremos este primer
punto y llevaremos x 5 y a1
y ahí tendrán nuestro primer valor la
segunda coordenada nos indica que cuando
x vale 10 bien vale 2 tomaremos este
punto y lo llevaremos a 10 en x y a 2 en
g
y aquí estará nuestro siguiente punto
finalmente esta tercera coordenada nos
indica que cuando x vale 15 lleva al dra
3 tomaremos este punto y llevaremos
x 15 y 3
de esta manera se grafican nuestras dos
sucesiones si a nosotros nos preguntan
volvamos a hacer espacio si a nosotros
nos preguntan
que los términos en la sucesión son que
veces términos en la sucesión de x
podemos considerar que es un quinto
porque porque bien si lo dividimos entre
5 tendremos un quinto de la misma manera
que si sacamos el factor común en este
caso que es 2
vamos a dividir entre 21 10 entre 25 se
dan cuenta es otra vez un quinto
sucederá lo mismo si tomamos el factor
común de este tercer coordenada
tendremos como factor común de 15 y de 3
pues el 3
3 entre 3 115 entre 35 una vez más es un
quinto así es que podemos decir que los
términos en la sucesión de james son un
quinto
a veces los términos de la asociación de
x vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta
y es correcta